What would be your recommendation, full of my dad's continued nausea?
So nausea is difficult when you're trying to gain weight and trying not to lose weight.
When you have cancer and you've got nausea, nothing sounds good, nothing.
You can't keep things out of worse if you're vomiting.
There are several products that I've recommended for years.
That is an essential oil called diegize that's branded by young living and it has gingery
and it's some other things that I'd like to use.
Just take a couple drops of my finger, take diegize or they put it on my tongue, that seemed
to help.
There's another product by herb farm that's more of an herbal product, an herbal spray
that's called nut down nausea, that's specific for nausea.
That can be helpful.
There's a product called ducts of amaca combination which is a holiopath from professional formulas.
I like that product.
That's just a straight holiopath, so holiopath that's based in a water-based liquid which
I like that product because holiopaths are so powerful, it works so well and that product
does, and holiopaths don't make you just taking it, so some people will go, I can't take
that herb, you know, that makes me nausea just taking it out.
All right, can't even take that essential oil, it makes me nausea just taking that.
Well, the holiopath world, so that's a good product to take for that, so those are the three
things that I recommend.
The diegize essential oil is one that not now nausea product by herb farm is the other
at the ducts holiopath by the professional formulas with the herb.